für studer fleischesser mystisch zur
sorge wie es dir geschlachtet wird 650
die kälber und rinder werden pro jahr im
schlachthof netz geht und hundert sowie
da auf dem hof
der schweizer ist die laufleistung leben
acht rinder aber schon bevor ich
unterwegs sehen wie es mit dem fleisch
wird oder fleisch ist müsste der
parasiten detail der geschichte genauer
morgen wenn ich da wirklich gesehen ein
ich sehe aber vielleicht wäre wichtig
dass man mal wie raneburger mona vetsch
mit bierhoff schlachtung gut vorbereitet
auf alles gefasst
das ist mona mit drin
also schön vielen stall und du gemacht
mit einem stapel der webseite der
entwickler und almir sogolj erhole und
ich aus kaarst will als kind bin ja noch
les maxi werde jetzt doch li und die
ratinger amtsgericht ein riesig und
parlament seien es oft recht sind eine
gruppe zusammen also das mit grund wieso
herweg talentierte buch geschrieben
es sind kurze zocker bin und lieber vor
der wackeren und wir wollen hat wie viel
hast dann und wann ins 18
und auch zu helfen
ja ich habe 17
der schmähliche er ist ein motor für das
mutterhaus werden das motorrad rechne
ich nicht und werde mich fühle und da
noch diese zurufe und den lauf der zeit
für ihn dass wir helfen hoffen dass
zunächst nicht vor
[Musik]
der schaltet erfasst von lore gang in
die heimische rauße bündner grauvieh
extremist
ja die richtige richtung
[Musik]
die hätten name oder augen eigenen
charakter das geht doch hier war immer
nett ich habe hier ja hallo ja er ist ja
eine zahlstelle ja geil dass ich 19 war
und bis dahin wirklich bühne stehen ist
etwas für sie heißt regulator also
schoki fried romanisch die wacht einfach
nicht das ist zu wenig der erste war
dürfte sich ob er wie möglich ein
experte verwies deshalb möchten wir
wollen berufsfelder verachtet oder böse
zu schaffen hier gut passen wenn sich
der partner fritz eigenartig linie aus
gründen
ich bin offenbar wachse aber
geschlachtet polizei rufen hof der
schorsch und sind nur gezeigt darum wie
das abläuft
zur strafe und denn das tier auf der
straße und das tier zurück gefahren
müssten die ferne frage stellen wieso
merz gibt bestäubern mit butter braten
und sind hinter der hertha brachte schon
morgen dahinter bei ihren fans zurück
wie sie über bed bath & body und die
sagt sie war betrunken und hatte meist
besser aus dennoch so virtuos und
besuchen und hatte mit dem ziel über je
nachdem auf der straße jungs fixiert so
dass mit unserem verkauft
danach konzentriert und beine sind
abstrakt die irdische sicherer wand
womit bedeutung gastiert in soho league
völlig spa nicht verlieren sagen dass
abgesteckt das ist extrem niedrig das
ist ja das ist schlachtrufen hof damit
der tiertransport stress ersparen
das ist die große ausnahme ich werde dir
herrlich nur gott 100 rinder
geschlachtet decken über 650.000 rinder
und kälber geschlachtet
dem schorsch und der claudia ich sowieso
vieles eliane tisch sie sind zwei query
stiko beiden durchgänge kunst studierte
geschmack von pure hoch sind noch immer
so um ruf tal vor fünf jahren claudia
und der schorsch ihrem leben ganz neue
richtige die hände biohofs baustelle
brachte mit ackerbau fläche und viel
[Musik]
große namen pure 1 26
georges sind fahrt durch arzt claudia
und unsere die arztfamilie zu dir hat
sie ihm ong bak
das problem scheint dir
na ja das macht zu sehen will
menschlich getreide alles menschen und
macht sie auf dem berg wird vor allem
morgen das thema tiere dazu mein buch
zum thema bis das was man arbeitet gegen
der acker und dass der kreislauf
geschlossen
[Musik]
der hof betriebe schorsch und claudia
mit genannt auch wenn sie im moment mit
der eu verbunden ist ist der ignatz
der mittlere tour haben sie vier das
alte leben als student den sieg mit
wechsel claudia vermisse dich und deinen
und weint möglichkeiten von der stadt
[Musik]
das leben aus büren sieht ihre vorabend
wir vertraut
[Musik]
ruhe ist die heimaufgabe tans kunde rund
7 schaffte claudia unter georges
verbuchen
für sie steht auf dem hof sehr konkret
und hanf ist anders als die kunst alles
irgendwie sie
[Musik]
trier zu bringen acht durchsuchte weiter
profile über am start
[Applaus]
hier sind wir zum kuscheln zum strich
allein und so und die andere die erhebt
und pflegt man genau gleich
endlich gibt der vater und sich brav auf
seine schule knips team mit genuss doch
es bald soweit verdruss
[Musik]
idyllisch vom auf dem biohof im
domleschg rühren aber eine ruine steht
zum letzten mal unter leitung claudia
ebert für die fleischproduktion und
machen vieles selber wenn sie es dir an
meiner grossverteiler rezepte zwei halb
musik franken über mainz fleisch selber
von marktredwitz dort hätte ihre sache
braucht sie im hofladen und via internet
50 franken im jahr
trotz viel arbeit den die
eigeninitiative ronny direktzahlungen
vom bund wird aus ihnen die bedrohung
die home sweet mit am tisch sind auch
ihren lehrling und in zivil die
entschlossen ist teamwork
wirklich rundum du bist du am boden bist
gar nix wie vor so frais glaubt also ich
werde schöne hat sie die musik da
braucht der buch und protokolle studio
solltet ihr leben ist hätte so viel muss
er wohl jetzt hab ich so herzog geboren
ist oder evelyn mit not an ihrer schule
und macht auch schon abonniert ja und
das ist das motto sparen ja soviel ja
ganze büro werner schuster
aber dem nicht eine art besser studiert
bitburg oder versicherung heilig super
studium und praxis merken wir hilfe rund
um also nach bruder wo braucht man also
unterstützte und wo man eine maschine
ausländerbehörde frau genutzt wenn
wochen betragen müssen mit aus dass wir
zwei so also sind die vampire ihren
eigenen weg finden 6 mit dem art pflanze
vor alte getreidesorten oder effizient
zu ihrem tier
die ache mit bienen luft weil und werde
dabei mit schlauch steht dafür die ich
wollte das jetzt war ich als nächstes
musste war sie ja also dieser wende
hatte meisten der fast schon
ausgestorben und erstaunt sagte schütz
ist ja selber beste fordert das stück
retro ist doch höchst dir einfach machen
eigentlich findet also anhand der
anderen hat 15 jahre unter dem titel das
lernen von metzgerei vv drüber und dann
besteht die finanzmärkte
also dessen herde die dws wissen ja
gestimmt werden ließ der gruppe blieb
dass wir die natur und das match völlig
wertlos werden hierfür soll aus und gibt
hierzu benötigen wird es ab passten was
ist los in neuenburg und trainieren und
und manchester und niederschlag spielt
nach gut
ich denke eigentlich dass ganz viele
jungs ganz ganz ruhig und eher
profitieren
der schlachthof werde drei hinteren
minutentakt netz geht noch eine abfahrt
wo bis zu acht stunden der schorsch und
claudia wenn es anders machen als töten
gibt es das überhaupt politisch lacht
ich die frage mit ihnen unruhige nacht
[Musik]
auf der einen seite die friedliche
stimmung auf der anderen seite wird die
zwei stunden beendet zum leben offenbar
hof gehört beides dazu dass voraus wurde
jedes tieren wie zum beispiel auch
zuhauf oder foursquare
das muss man so gut ausfüllen ja was los
wäre wenn weil das dir seinen zweck und
bin jetzt ein stammgast
baltische sowie claudia gott weg bis zu
8gb statischer orange nervös wie
erwartet auf der metzger und die ärztin
aber in den schwarzen langsamer fahren
warten wir wirklich so nicht eine kurve
wenn es gar nicht wie die preise schauen
und so absurd mit dem handlichen
aufbauend schon vorweg dieses schreibt
deshalb nicht wieso man wohl wenn ich
das meine lehren beste kompromiss
stellen menschen muss ich so ein auto
setzte das ist ein funktioniert
eigentlich arbeitet
ich glaube der schluckt im monat damit
heuer am richtigen platz
[Musik]
sie will den ärger macht auch schon so
damit sind möglichst normal ist
vorschriften verlangen
das schlachttier bild auf dem hof oder
andere tier trend werden muss jetzt wo
die reds den tanja albertine und der
metzger niki bl oder sind geht alles
schnell
jackman der micra blütenboden für sigrid
aber vorschrift
gut
der werden so wichtig wird
sowas hier ist
es geht nur noch nach hause hätte
schorsch seit die bewusst sie und
trotzdem macht sei nur gewesen
die andere rinder fresse wie thomas
wenning passiert
noch ein kurzes bleiberecht sekunde
zählt zu den schnitt als schlagader
machen
[Musik]
davon haben
die schlote
ich hoffe und ich mir alte aus aleppo
königsee
und liest ein kilo fleisch ist muss man
auch bereit sie für detail von der
geschicht
vorstand und das geld das nötig
sid
[Musik]
minute
ideal das perfekt laufen mit der uhrzeit
mit dem titel halten muss ist perfekt
im moment ja
jetzt haben wir nur dreiviertel stunde
bis das tier ist klar sie muss
[Musik]
extrem leid hier und hier auf
aus
das normale leben heißt kunden bleiben
der manager erwartet die show im
schlachthof bonaduz
der ort wo schlachters besetzte der
wenigsten konnte unerlaubt bekannten
dänischen pionier aber doof lage sind
streng
erst zwei toren im kanton schlachter das
so
das alles vorschriftsmäßig die ratslinke
am jahr bergbahn verantwortlich warum
die zeit nicht erst so weit ich war
schon so hoch schlachte gemacht
erstmalig das widerständen 9 und zum
anderen vorgang nicht jeder machen und
es ist von bezieht herr und
wahrscheinlich gar nicht sie halten wird
weggeschoben und denn für viele gar
nicht gebraucht also beispiel uhr
gestürzt dass er die harte schlacht
das passiert nicht optimal das ist super
dass tiere stark stand es plötzlich
ruhig gesehen
das geht schnell oder sehr stark weil er
schlug mit das bier aber weiß ja gar
nicht
und auch jetzt plötzlich da und dieser
die einzelnen stücke fleisch jetzt mal
wirklich im fleischbereich und jetzt als
lebensmittel
da ich da irgendwie schlecht dass das
nicht so schnell auf uns wissen dass die
achse umgehen kann und es ist eigentlich
nur noch nahrung und wenn man wenn man
das nämlich veganer nicht damit getan
haben wir ganz sicher anders als wenn
man fleisch es gibt vielleicht auch
viele fleischesser die das alles sehr
möchte aber sicherlich viele die das gar
nicht sehen möchte
ich möchte einfach das schnitzel auf dem
teller und
dreist ausbleibenden auf
auf dem hof schlachte wieder schwer die
schweiz nahm liebe aufwand und kosten
sind groß aber auch der fleischkonsum in
der schweizer geschichte sei man ja
öfters fleisch befreit wird
was hat sie denn wirklich nur gras
bringen wie sie wissen schluss macht den
unterschied ob du dir also jetzt auf dem
hof metzgers oder irgendwo im
schlachthaus vermied zwar mehr fantasie
bemerken das nicht und da mergens
dolmetscherin erlaufen american capital
es hat meistens 40 uhr ihnen und denken
das parkproblem merkst du wie sie mit
dir gott wenn sie wenn es nass ist jetzt
im la salsa schlagen oder kommt und wenn
es viel nassig denn muss sie mit
mitgeteilt warum beispiel den sind
nervös denn ist katrina sowie toben
dass das nicht bringt also ein paar
schlechte qualität und der märkte mit
die end das sind autoren empfehlen
ja so ist das wenn ein kredit schnell
fahren ist gesetzes und der die ganze
sache berechtigt und wie ist die
realität muss ich tag für tag der
schweizer aufspielt
nur wenn man muss meistens nicht mit
[Musik]
auf dem hof spiels ist wieder der alte
kreiert
[Musik]
hilfe claudia und dem song stuck genau
auskunft zu jetzt steht der name im
nachsetzen letzten steigen auch einen
blick auf das zwischen scirocco bleibt
wenn überhaupt überhaupt gedacht ich
muss ja ich bin hier aufgewachsen und
druckern mich zeigen hat sie da ja sehr
schmal ein
als ich das für euch ihre zieht wenn er
auf der alten stelle
so etwas ist gut im sommer herrschte zum
neuen woche und ja auch schon mal hoch
und die nazis das schöne ist ja mega
heiß und der doppelten buchwert ihre
zeit
dafür wie otto.de lang eingefroren
gebracht brachte dann irgendeine usa
zugesagt also ich mir sorgen zu machen
sie brachten blumen und der bleibt
spannend auch dass ich mir vorstelle war
schon sehr viel erreicht so eine phase
im leben und wenn gott wird aber eine
gewohnt sind
die so hell macht sollte diesen jukebox
der health spa langsam
[Musik]
für den duft weit und ich zurück im nie
welt noch deine dritte wäre nie möglich
vor der fleischtheke stock
[Musik]
ich bin gespannt was die sendebus gelöst
hat geht es für ein gutes jahr zum tier
schlachten oder ist ihr schlachten
person bis verwerflich wie man für ein
kommentar und mittendrin und andere doch
seien die regional fasste wenn der kanal
da abonnieren